Le solveur variationnel quantique d'igenvecteurs, ou VQE, est l'un des premiers algorithmes hybrides quantique-classique, et il est
intéressant pour plusieurs raisons. Premièrement, comme on le verra dans cette vidéo, c'est une approche prometteuse pour certains types de problèmes. Deuxièmement, c'est important
historiquement et cela a ouvert la voie à de nombreux algorithmes améliorés tels que adapt VQE.
Et enfin, VQE est assez simple. Il est facile de comprendre ce que font les ordinateurs quantique et classique dans cet algorithme
et comment ils interagissent. Il y a quatre composantes principales d'un calcul VQE.
Premièrement, il y a un opérateur, souvent un Hamiltonien, qu'on appellera H, qui décrit une propriété du système qu'
on souhaite optimiser. Une autre façon de dire cela est qu'on cherche l'igenvecteur de cet opérateur qui
correspond à la valeur propre minimale. On appelle souvent cet igenvecteur l'état fondamental.
Ensuite, il y a un ansatz — un mot signifiant approche. C'est un circuit quantique qui prépare un état quantique approximant
l'igenvecteur que tu cherches. En réalité, l'ansatz est une famille de circuits quantiques, car certains des gates dans
l'ansatz sont paramétrés. C'est-à-dire qu'on leur fournit un paramètre qu'on peut faire varier. Cette famille de circuits quantiques
peut préparer une famille d'états quantiques approximant l'état fondamental.
Ensuite, on a besoin d'un estimateur — un moyen d'estimer la valeur d'expectation de l'opérateur H sur l'état quantique variationnel courant.
Parfois, ce qu'on cherche vraiment c'est simplement cette valeur d'expectation, qu'on
appelle une fonction de coût. D'autres fois, on s'intéresse à une fonction plus complexe qui peut quand même s'écrire à partir d'
une ou plusieurs valeurs d'expectation.
Enfin, on a besoin d'un optimiseur classique — un algorithme qui fait varier les paramètres pour essayer de minimiser cette fonction de coût.
Décrivons le problème qu'on veut résoudre et l'approche générale avant d'aborder le rôle que joue le quantique. On
peut formuler de nombreux problèmes d'optimisation critiques pour la science et l'industrie comme des problèmes de valeurs matricielles. Couramment, on
veut la valeur propre minimale de la matrice et l'igenvecteur qui lui correspond. La matrice H pourrait être
un Hamiltonien décrivant l'énergie d'un système physique. Et la valeur propre minimale serait l'énergie de l'état fondamental
E0, et l'igenvecteur serait l'état fondamental quantique correspondant, souvent noté psi sub 0.
Ou la matrice pourrait décrire une fonction de coût complexe associée à des problèmes d'optimisation combinatoire,
comme en logistique, et l'état propre s_opt serait une solution optimale du
problème, comme une chaîne binaire étiquetant une coupe dans un graphe d'un réseau de distribution. En pratique,
il est courant d'entendre le terme Hamiltonien pour toutes les matrices d'intérêt, même en dehors des sciences physiques. Supposons
qu'on s'intéresse à une matrice avec n lignes et n colonnes. De tels problèmes peuvent être résolus rapidement et exactement avec des
solveurs classiques pour n allant jusqu'à quelques centaines ou milliers, sans aucune hypothèse sur la matrice. Pour les matrices
creuses — celles avec principalement des zéros comme entrées — cela peut être bien plus grand, avec n pouvant atteindre un milliard, même sur un laptop.
Mais pour des problèmes vraiment énormes dépassant ces chiffres, des méthodes approximatives ou heuristiques sont souvent nécessaires.
Plus la matrice est grande et moins elle est creuse, moins le problème est tractable et plus des astuces ingénieuses doivent être employées. Supposons que ta matrice soit tellement
grande que la diagonalisation exacte n'est pas une option. Supposons de plus que tu en saches assez sur ton problème pour pouvoir
faire quelques hypothèses sur la structure globale de l'état cible et que tu veuilles sonder des états similaires à ton
estimation initiale pour voir si ton coût ou ton énergie peut être réduit davantage. C'est une approche variationnelle, et c'est une méthode
utilisée quand la diagonalisation exacte n'est pas possible sur un ordinateur classique. Cela fonctionnerait comme suit.
Premièrement, tu fais un état de départ avec quelques paramètres theta que tu vas faire varier.
Bien que cette estimation initiale puisse être aléatoire, ce n'est pas conseillé. On veut utiliser la connaissance du problème en question
pour adapter notre estimation au maximum.
Deuxièmement, on calculerait la valeur d'expectation de l'opérateur avec le système dans cet état.
Troisièmement, on modifierait les paramètres variationnels et on recommencerait.
Quatrièmement, on utiliserait les informations accumulées sur le paysage des états possibles dans ton sous-espace variationnel pour faire de meilleures et meilleures
estimations et se rapprocher de l'état cible.
Le principe variationnel garantit que notre état variationnel ne peut pas donner une valeur propre inférieure à celle de l'
état fondamental cible. Donc plus la valeur d'expectation est basse, meilleure est notre approximation de l'état fondamental.
Parlons de la difficulté de chaque étape dans cette approche.
Définir ou mettre à jour les paramètres est computationnellement facile. La difficulté est de choisir des paramètres initiaux
physiquement motivés et utiles. Utiliser les informations accumulées des itérations précédentes pour mettre à jour les paramètres de manière
à se rapprocher de l'état fondamental n'est pas trivial. Mais il existe des algorithmes d'optimisation classiques qui font
cela de façon assez efficace. Cette optimisation classique n'est coûteuse que parce qu'elle peut nécessiter de nombreuses
itérations. Dans le pire des cas, le nombre d'itérations peut croître exponentiellement avec n.
L'étape individuelle la plus coûteuse computationnellement est presque certainement le calcul de la valeur d'expectation de ta matrice pour un
état donné. La matrice n×n doit agir sur le vecteur à n éléments, ce qui correspond à environ n au carré
opérations de multiplication dans le pire des cas. Cela doit être fait à chaque itération des paramètres. Pour des matrices
très grandes, cela a un coût computationnel élevé. Maintenant, imagine confier cette partie du
calcul à un ordinateur quantique. Au lieu de calculer cette valeur d'expectation, tu l'estimes en préparant l'
état s de theta sur l'ordinateur quantique en utilisant ton ansatz variationnel, puis en faisant des mesures.
Analysons cela un peu. H n'est généralement pas facile à mesurer. Par exemple, il pourrait être composé de nombreux
opérateurs de Pauli X, Y et Z qui ne commutent pas.
Mais H peut être écrit comme une combinaison linéaire de termes H_alpha, dont chacun est facilement mesurable. Par exemple,
des opérateurs de Pauli ou des groupes d'opérateurs de Pauli commutant bit à bit. La
valeur d'expectation de H sur l'état S est la somme pondérée des valeurs d'expectation des termes constituants H_alpha.
Cette expression est valable pour tout état S, mais on l'utilisera spécifiquement avec notre état variationnel S de theta.
Chacun des termes h_alpha peut être mesuré m fois, donnant des échantillons de mesure s_alpha_j avec j allant de
1 à m, et retourne une valeur d'expectation et un écart-type. On peut sommer
ces termes et propager les erreurs à travers la somme.
Cela ne nécessite pas de multiplication à grande échelle ni aucun processus qui évolue nécessairement comme n au carré. À la place,
cela nécessite de multiples mesures sur l'ordinateur quantique. Si tu n'en as pas besoin de trop, cette approche pourrait être
efficace. Et c'est la partie quantique de VQE. Mais parlons des raisons pour lesquelles cela pourrait ne pas être efficace. Une raison
d'avoir de nombreuses mesures est de réduire l'incertitude statistique dans tes estimations pour des calculs de très haute précision.
Une autre raison est le nombre de chaînes de Pauli nécessaires pour couvrir toute ta matrice. Comme les matrices de Pauli plus l'
identité couvrent l'espace de tous les opérateurs d'une dimension donnée, on est garantis
de pouvoir écrire notre matrice d'intérêt comme une somme pondérée d'opérateurs de Pauli comme on l'a fait avant. Ici, C_alpha est un
coefficient numérique et H_alpha est une chaîne d'opérateurs de Pauli agissant sur tous les qubits décrivant ton système.
H_alpha aurait une forme comme celle-ci, où le n-ième opérateur de Pauli en partant de la droite agit sur le n-ième qubit. On peut donc
mesurer notre opérateur en mesurant une série d'opérateurs de Pauli. Mais on ne peut pas mesurer tous ces opérateurs de Pauli
simultanément. Les opérateurs de Pauli, à l'exclusion de l'identité, ne commutent pas entre eux s'ils sont
associés au même qubit. Par exemple, on peut mesurer I Z IIZ et ZZ
XZ simultanément, car on peut mesurer I et Z simultanément pour le troisième
qubit. Et on peut connaître I et X simultanément pour le premier qubit. Mais on ne peut pas
mesurer tous les Z et ZZ ZX simultanément, car Z et X ne
commutent pas et agissent tous les deux sur le qubit zéro.
On décompose donc notre matrice H en une somme de Pauli agissant sur différents qubits.
Certains éléments de cette somme peuvent être mesurés tous en même temps. On appelle cela un groupe de Pauli commutants. Selon
le nombre de termes non commutants, on peut avoir besoin de nombreux de ces groupes. Appelons le nombre de tels groupes de Pauli commutants
n_gcp.
Si n_gcp est petit, cela pourrait bien fonctionner.
Si H a des millions de groupes, ce ne sera pas utile. Tu enregistres la valeur d'expectation ou la fonction de coût
pour l'ensemble de paramètres theta utilisé dans ton état, puis tu mets à jour les paramètres au fil du temps. Tu pourrais utiliser les
valeurs d'expectation ou les valeurs de fonction de coût estimées pour approximer un gradient de ta fonction de coût dans le
sous-espace des états échantillonnés par ton ansatz.
Il existe des optimiseurs classiques avec gradient et sans gradient. Les deux souffrent de potentiels problèmes d'entraînabilité comme
les multiples minima locaux et les grandes régions de l'espace des paramètres avec un gradient proche de zéro, appelées plateaux arides.
Alors VQE va-t-il résoudre tous tes problèmes les plus difficiles ? Non. Mais être meilleur pour tous les calculs n'a jamais été l'objectif. On a
changé ce qui détermine le coût computationnel. Regarde ce qu'on a échangé. On est passé d'un processus
dont la complexité dépend uniquement de la dimension de la matrice à un processus qui dépend de la précision requise et du nombre d'
opérateurs de Pauli non commutants qui composent la matrice. Ce dernier point n'a pas d'équivalent en informatique classique.
Sur la base de ces nouvelles dépendances, pour les matrices creuses ou les matrices impliquant peu de chaînes de Pauli non commutantes, ce
processus pourrait être utile. C'est le cas pour les systèmes de spins en interaction. Par exemple, pour les matrices denses, il peut être
moins utile. On sait, par exemple, que les systèmes chimiques ont souvent des Hamiltoniens impliquant des centaines, des milliers, voire
des millions de chaînes de Pauli. Des travaux intéressants ont été réalisés pour réduire ce nombre de termes, mais
les systèmes chimiques pourraient être mieux adaptés à certains des autres algorithmes qu'on discutera dans ce cours.
L'utilisation efficace de VQE nécessite également qu'on connaisse les attributs de notre état cible et qu'on puisse choisir un bon
état initial physiquement motivé ainsi qu'un bon ansatz avec relativement peu de paramètres variationnels. Cela peut être
assez difficile. VQE démontre comment les forces des ordinateurs classiques et quantiques peuvent être combinées
sans ajouter les méthodes plus récentes. VQE ne nous aide pas à résoudre des problèmes qui sont intractables pour les ordinateurs classiques, mais
il continue de jouer un rôle dans le développement d'algorithmes. Et VQE nous enseigne aussi que transférer une étape des ordinateurs classiques
aux ordinateurs quantiques n'est ni meilleur ni pire pour toutes les applications. Plutôt,
cela change les facteurs qui déterminent l'efficacité de ton algorithme. C'est une leçon générale importante en informatique
hybride quantique-classique.